okay okay this is bad this is really bad
but just remember
we are not going to jail we didn't do it
we're innocent guilty on all charges
oh
guilty
very cool
cool
cool cool cool
cool all right thanks
okay here's what esther remembers about
the night that she was around she was
either at our restaurant or the movies
or doing something else and she was
either alone or with people the only
thing she was absolutely sure of is that
i seemed like a very nice boy which is
not relevant to the case but did make me
feel very good this is stupid
it was 20 years ago no one remembers
anything
i'm beginning to think maybe we should
climb out on that ledge and see how the
perp got in i was gonna say give up what
right after i came up with that
incredible ledge thing terry we're ten
stories up you can handle that sarge i'm
not scared of heights okay i'm scared of
bees i'm scared of snakes and i'm scared
that the knicks might never be good
again but i am not scared of heights
we're gonna die we're gonna die we're
gonna die we're gonna die we're gonna
die we're gonna die we're gonna die
i would appreciate it if you didn't tell
anyone about my window let's freak out
you can lock me up but one day i'll get
out of here and i'll come for you i'll
come for all of you hey warden what's up
next time don't wait too long to spit
the cookie i've been waiting in here for
four minutes and it's gross man it
really is okay snitch time what's up
with romero all right he's got a
delivery coming in on wednesday night
one of the cafeteria workers is
smuggling something in with the produce
ah great see you thursday wait what
you're just gonna leave me in here in
solitary you spit in a guard's face
that's five days in the hole yeah but i
mean you made me do that well we don't
want anybody getting suspicious huh have
fun
[Music]
try not to go crazy
okay
no big deal
five days is nothing i'm not afraid to
be alone with my thoughts my thoughts
are awesome die hard sex on a cruise
ship pizza bagel restaurant my father
never loved me i'm gonna die alone oh
boy that happened fast guard
larry i need to talk to you about an
issue with our shared fence yes i also
need to discuss this shared fence issue
with you okay they're out of earshot why
are you up so early no reason just
excited to face a new day oh because
ever since we've been down here you've
been a little
depressed
have i
no
don't eat the burrito
okay fine i may have had a teensy bit of
trouble adjusting when we first got here
for like
six teensy little months
i gotta find ocampo before rosa does i'm
so wound up i can't focus oh are you
flipping out about tiandra getting
kicked off so you think you can dance
definitely not well you should be her
nae nae was non-puree
i know what's happening i'm finally
hydrated and it's unlocking my brain's
full potential it's too much for me i'm
limitless i don't think water makes you
jittery and does if it's laced with
caffeine
you dosed my water you just drank 960
cups of coffee oh that sprains why i
know talk butter
me having sterk
good luck solving that case
why would you drink more my brain wants
its fast juice so
apparently the new captain survived and
his heart attack not the craziest thing
that happened at the precinct today
we kissed
like three hours ago
yes
we did kiss each other
for reals
reals reals
listen i know you said you don't want to
date cops but
i really like you
i like you too
good
but what if we start dating and it makes
things weird at work so let's just
keep it light and breezy
see where it goes totally
yeah so how do we keep it light and
breezy
i know
a comprehensive set of rules how am i
attracted to you doesn't matter i am go
rule one let's not tell anyone so we can
figure out what this is first smort rule
number two let's not put labels on it
we're not boyfriend and girlfriend we're
just
mermseep and jinglebin great rule number
three let's not have sex right away
cool
no doubt no doubt no doubt no doubt good
rule no sex good rule that was your
first stint in solitary it was nothing i
held it together oh
amy when'd you get here
you've come for my conjugal capabilities
you're looking
real good girl
oop pasta boobie no matter
i'll just build another one
more mashed potatoes
[Music]
sir
detective
so
how was your night of work i'm not
asking about your personal life i don't
care about you personally i mean i'm
neutral i mean who are you floundering
is worse than silence oh cool go go go
go go go no doubt no doubt no doubt
yeah it's elevator's slow huh that's
because you haven't pressed the button
[Music]
peralta are you eating an italian sub
for breakfast i am but amy said i should
eat more veggies so i got extra
pepperoni smort
excuse me
you need to watch yourself i'm sorry
cop
all right let's everybody just stay calm
here oh what are you going to arrest me
for dancing
you call that dancing
this
is dancing
what is happening i'm defusing the
situation
[Music]
[Applause]
oh why is my phone always dead i paid 13
for it don't worry
i got it
oh no my hands are covered in butter
from making butter i'm on it
record must record camera on all right
here we go dancing over situation
diffused
no
hey
give me those 20 pounders wait your turn
babysit this club no weightlifting you
can shoot that baby across the room come
on
what's going on i was stepping to her i
know but it wasn't a good time she was
holding a 20 pound weight that's
basically thor's hammer babe i can
handle myself cool yeah just you know
don't confront her when she's armed fine
seriously she was at lunch she didn't
have a weapon she had a fork that's like
four tiny shivs on a
what
stick
hell socks are just a noose waiting to
be braided
we're playing hearts in the wrong hands
every playing card is like a throwing
star i've been going at him for six
hours he won't say a word the guy's a
brick wall not to worry sarge i'll take
it from here hope you boys brought
popcorn cause i'm about to put on a show
well well well i hear you don't like
answering questions marcos that's fine
by me cause i'm not asking
oop handle fell off
nope so
looks like we're locked in
that's bad news for you cause you're
trapped in here with a psycho
has anyone tried it from the outside
lock's broken gotta call facilities copy
that no rush as i said
i got all the time and the worst little
woman here right do you feel any air
coming out of that vent i got nothing we
got an eta on facilities at least 45
minutes i'd have checked all this paint
for lead right and the room for asbestos
i feel like i'm sucking on a tailpipe in
here marcos everybody get away from the
mirror
come on i can't breathe i can't breathe
hey calm down man i'll confess just stop
freaking out what i did it
i robbed him boom and that's how it's
done i was faking the whole thing to
break them i could have stayed in here
forever good cause facility's gonna be a
couple hours we're gonna die in here
you